Ah, technology.
A double-edged sword of our own making that
can provide both ultimate convenience and
the threat of a grim future ruled by unfeeling
machines.
Well, maybe the stakes aren’t that high…
yet, but our overreliance on technology can
have some terrible consequences.
The number of traffic accidents continues
to increase year by year, as our main mode
of overland transportation also puts us in
harm’s way for longer and longer portions
of our day.
The internet can allow us to access any information
we may desire, but it can spread misinformation
twice as fast.
And what about video games?
An interactive artistic medium that can provide
simulated experiences so vivid that many of
us can eventually lose interest in our real
lives.
What starts off as a fun indulgence in our
favorite hobby can quickly spiral into an
obsession.
The risks and rewards of virtual space are
satisfyingly predictable compared to the chaos
of modern living, and sometimes we just can’t
stop ourselves from striving for a few more
easy wins.
Minutes, hours, and even days can go by without
any apparent activity on our side of the screen,
and yet the world of the video game has changed
drastically due to our actions.
But, at a certain point, that initial rush
of dopamine wears off, and you find that you
need a much greater challenge in order to
feel any sense of accomplishment.
So you choose to pick up some harder video
games, and you grind away until you can complete
them just as easily.
But that’s not enough either.
Surely, there must be even tougher games out
there.
Games that will never go easy on you.
Games that won’t allow you to make even
a single mistake.
Games that make you proud of the frankly inexcusable
amount of hours of your life that you’ve
spent sitting in the dark, clutching a controller,
squinting at your screen.
You need a game that can do all of that and
more.
And because you’ve effectively given up
your chances at ever being a social butterfly,
you could also use something to help you mitigate
the overwhelming loneliness that now constantly
defines your everyday life.
Well, worry no longer – you weary, downtrodden
gamer, you – because here at the SCP Foundation,
we’ve cooked up a one-of-a-kind mod that
is sure to redefine your gaming experience.
If this doesn’t turn out to be game of the
year, I don't know what could be.
Among Us 2, maybe?
The latest in a long line of Last Of Us Remakes?
What about Half-Life 3?
I digress.
Introducing the Foundation’s brand new killer
app: the cutting-edge tactical heuristic algorithms
of SCP-1633 combined with the 24/7 companionship
of SCP-1471 Mal0.
I can tell by your expression that you’re
already eager for a playtest, but slow down,
we need to catch all the normies out there
up to speed.
Let’s start with the digital canine companion
that is all the rage, SCP-1471 - or should
I say Ma10 version 1.0.0 - a euclid class
SCP object which comes in the form of a free
downloadable app for your smartphone.
There have never been any reviews of this
app for as long as it has existed, but honestly,
are you really going to trust the words of
a bunch of crooked reviewers when you could
find out for yourself?
Words to live by: don’t trust anyone who
isn’t part of your precious gaming hobby.
The description of Ma10 version 1.0.0.
reads - Never settle for those awkward feelings
of being alone ever again.
MalO is an exciting and interactive experience
that will keep you engaged and intrigued.
The anxiety of social situations can be nerve-racking,
but after just a few hours of MalO you will
soon forget all about those painful emotions
of disappointment.
Be part of the new craze that is quickly becoming
the next social substitute.
Remember, the more you participate, the more
MalO will engage you.
Your experience is completely up to you.
Absolutely NO ADS.
Enjoy!
The app has never received an update, but
that’s because SCP-1471 has been a completely
functional experience since its release.
All one needs to do is download the app and
within a matter of hours, Ma10 version 1.0.0
will begin to send the user photographs of
familiar locations.
These can include photographs of the user's
work, home, or public places they often frequent:
such as cafes and nightclubs.
In the case of you - a complete shut-in gamer
- these photographs would probably be limited
to the interior of your favorite gaming room.
When was the last time you cleaned up those
pizza boxes?
Regardless of where the images were apparently
taken, each one will contain a canine humanoid
with a skull for a face.
Say hello to your new best friend, Ma10, or
SCP-1471-A if we’re using the approved designation.
Ma10’s app will continue to send you photographs
for as long as you have it installed, and
because there is no way to uninstall it no
matter how hard you try, you’ll be getting
intimately close to home selfies for the rest
of your days.
Doesn’t it feel good to have such a loyal
friend as Ma10?
Of course, there’s only so much you can
gain from photographs alone.
You’re a gamer, darn it.
And what you want is interactivity!
But don’t worry about that part.
We’ve got you more than covered with SCP-1633,
which may, in fact, be the most challenging
video game ever programmed by mortal hands.
Hell, it even gives many games programmed
by anomalous hands a run for their money.
While it was never released to market and
doesn’t even have a working title, the steampunk
adventure that awaits you within SCP-1633
is bolstered by highly sophisticated tactical
heuristic algorithms.
In this third-person Squad-based action-RPG,
you can switch between four playable characters.
The Marksman - who specializes in long-range
weaponry
The Alchemist - with potions and chemicals
to control the battlefield
The Rogue - a stealth-oriented character who
catches enemies unaware and assassinates them
And of course, The Thug - a tough-as-nails
melee combatant with increased health and
durability.
It doesn’t really matter who you choose
because most playthroughs of SCP-1633 always
end the same way.
That being said, your hand-eye coordination
and reflexes are second to none, and they
are also quite possibly your best qualities.
Let’s set you up with the Marksman as your
main character, since all those shooters you’ve
played will definitely help your aim.
And trust me, you’re going to need it.
The story mode of SCP-1633 will put you up
against a slew of victorian-era rascals and
miscreants, all of which are pulled straight
from the penny dreadfuls.
There’s even some classic fantasy races
mixed in from the works from good old Professor
Tolkein himself - dwarves, elves, goblins,
the works.
It’s a little generic, but why worry about
the story when the gameplay is what’ll really
get you hooked.
There’s a final boss at the end of the game
known as Kr'th'nar trying to destroy the entire
world, you need to stop it - you know, the
usual RPG storyline.
You’ve stopped dozens of ancient entities,
demon lords, corrupt godlings, and unspeakable
calamities in your time.
This Kr’th’nar will be one more for the
record books.
Par for the course.
Are you ready, player one?
You’ll be dropped straight into The Marksman’s
shoes, fighting for his and your life against
Kr’th’nar hordes of henchmen.
But you won’t be doing it alone.
After all, you’ve got the rest of your squad,
and a mysterious companion whose true intentions
will reveal themselves in due time.
We did say we modded the game after all.
So let’s play.
Your first two hours won’t be anything to
write home about, not that you ever leave
your home these days.
The AI of SCP-1633 will seem to be barely
functioning, a buggy mess where enemies only
charge in a straight line towards your character.
Your Marksman will be able to easily take
them down in a hailstorm of projectiles.
At three hours in, things start getting a
bit more interesting as the tactical heuristic
algorithms kick in.
The enemies that hold long-range weapons will
shoot at you from a distance, while the close-range
ones move towards you in a serpentine pattern
before attacking in melee.
This is more like it: not the most challenging,
but the game is clearly increasing in difficulty.
You also think you see a dark figure with
a skull for a face lurking around corners
and following your squad.
But with all the glitches, it’s hard to
tell if this is an intentional part of the
game or not.
At five hours, enemies that previously showed
limited signs of strategy are now using cover
effectively, and will attack with alchemical
splash weapons such as grenades to deal damage
to your ranged characters and lure your squad
into melee range.
They still aren’t that much of a challenge,
but the fact that they now exhibit a clear
self-preservation instinct means that they
are fighting to win.
This is also when your help officially arrives.
You’re in the middle of a shootout when
you see an enemy about to throw another one
of those frustrating splash weapons.
You duck behind your cover and prepare to
take a hit, when suddenly the grenade is snatched
out of the enemy’s hand and tossed in the
opposite direction to explode harmlessly.
This is the work of SCP-1471-A, who has now
arrived in the game world as an NPC ally.
For the next several hours of gameplay, Ma10
continues to provide interference by preventing
any splash weapons from being thrown.
It’ll sneak up on enemies and take their
weapons, disrupt their cover by pushing movable
boxes and trash cans out of the way, and even
catch the splash weapons in her mouth like
a dog would catch frisbee before chucking
them away.
While it never directly deals damage to the
enemies, its mischievous antics are very efficient
at protecting you from harm.
As luck would have it, the enemies can’t
seem to interact with Ma10, and are baffled
as this invisible force continues to throw
off their strategies.
Ma10 will use this to its advantage as well
as yours, by appearing at enemy ambush points
and using sign language to communicate warnings
to you as the player.
Having Ma10 around starts to feel a little
bit like cheating, but keep in mind, the game
is starting to adapt to your skill level and
will soon begin to employ advanced strategies
to mess with you.
All the Ma10 mod does is even the playing
field.
The next big leap in enemy intelligence occurs
at the 12 hour mark.
Kr’th’nar is still running rampant in
the world of SCP-1633 and it's going to take
your entire squad of steampunk heroes, and
a lonely man’s best friend - Ma10 - to stop
this big bad evil guy.
The final boss will possess the highest level
of intelligence that the algorithms are capable
of, and it’ll make that known to you the
second you step into the arena.
For the majority of your gameplay the enemies
have focused on countering the marksman, since
you’ve relied on that character’s ranged-weapon
style.
But they’ve come to realize that you’re
too much of a pro-MLG gigachad to ever lose
a fair encounter, so Kr’th’nar does the
unthinkable and targets the alchemist, rogue,
and thug first.
It throws all of its most powerful attacks
at the members of your squad you aren’t
controlling, forcing you to waste resources
in order to keep them alive or switch to them
in order to dodge fatal blows.
Whenever you aren’t in command of the marksman,
Kr’th’nar will strike the character with
a strong melee attack that forces to take
control back.
Ma10 is still unable or unwilling to deal
damage to the boss, so it very much seems
like you are on your own.
Your squad is in shambles, your focus is starting
to wane.
After all that you’ve been through in this
gaming challenge, it might be the final boss
that makes you throw in the towel.
Then, a dialogue box appears.
It’s from Ma10.
Don’t give up hope, user.
I’ve had so much fun playing with you, and
I know that you have what it takes.
You never needed a friend before me, and you
can win against Kr’th’nar just like you’ve
won against every other final boss you’ve
ever faced.
You got this, buddy.
Your best friend, MA10
It felt overly sentimental, but something
about this message fills you with the determination
to keep going.
You call upon all of your gaming knowledge,
all of your skill, all of your passion, and
with pinpoint precision, you guide your squad
to defeat Kr’th’nar in record-breaking
time.
You sit back in your gaming chair, exhilarated
and finally satisfied.
This truly was the ultimate gaming experience,
and all you needed was a little help from
your friend.
Now go check out SCP-1471 - MalO Version 1.0.0
and What if SCP-1471 MalO Was Put Inside SCP-914?
For more absurd Mal0 antics to brighten your
day!